[Música]
e
a loja toluca gracias por venir hoy y
hoy los quiero invitar a que recuerden
de los libros de su infancia donde
tenían muchos animales y les preguntaban
sus papás dónde está el león y todos
contestaban a es la imagen de arriba a
la derecha y cuando sus papás les
preguntaban pues pues por qué es león y
no tigre ustedes decían es la melena son
los dientes el rugido o porque el león
es el rey de la selva y está sonriendo
en las fotos
pero en cuanto vamos avanzando en
nuestro conocimiento de biología lo que
nos vamos dando cuenta es que resolver
una pregunta de qué es una especia no es
tan sencillo
y aquí les presento dos fotos de aves y
les pregunto ustedes creen que son la
misma especie levanten la mano sí o no
99% dice que sí
pero vamos a escucharlas
[Música]
y ahora a b2
aquellos con oído musical ya se habrán
dado cuenta de la respuesta pero para
aquellos que no déjenme les presento 2
alondras diferentes especies diferentes
la del oeste que vive en el en el oeste
de norteamérica y la alondra del este
que vive en el este de norteamérica y de
américa de central y que podemos ver
aquí en toluca ahora yo estoy siendo
súper injusta con ustedes porque si yo
voy al campo tampoco la reconozca de
vista
y la razón por las que no las reconozco
es porque mi trabajo es en plantas
entonces decidí hacer la misma pregunta
pero ahora con plantas y con mis amigos
e hice lo que cualquier científico
moderno hace estos días ir a mis redes
sociales y preguntarle a mis amigos si
el brócoli la col son la misma especie
y se sorprenderán no es saber que el 56
por ciento dice que si son la misma
especie y el 44% dice que son diferentes
ahora me muestra está sesgada porque
tengo muchos amigos botánicos
pero en caso de que no sepan
en el brócoli y la col vienen de esta
planta que se llama brassica oler asia y
la col es un nodo terminal de la planta
y el brócoli es la flor con el tallo y
compararlas es como comparar dos perros
uno chiquito y uno grande al final pero
al final práctica
ahora ya se habrán dado cuenta que las
apariencias de las especies engañan y
que no es suficiente con verlas para
poder decidir si una cosa es especie o
no en mi trabajo como científica una de
las más importantes contextos que
necesitamos saber para distinguir las
especies es la historia evolutiva por
ejemplo estas son garañón as del nevado
de toluca que comparten una historia
evolutiva de 50 millones de años
y la pregunta que me hago todos los días
y que trató de resolver en mi trabajo es
porque algunas de estas características
unidas a su historia evolutiva hacen que
las especies persistan por millones de
años o peor aún que se extinga
en una combinación de historia evolutiva
características que son medidas en campo
y en el herbario y matemáticas lo que
trato de medir es la extinción histórica
de las especies y lo que hemos
descubierto es que se extingue una
especie por cada millón de millón de
especies en un año pero cuando estos
modelos les agregamos no sólo las
matemáticas por el impacto humano
obtenemos la extinción actual y la
estadística incrementa 28 veces
esperamos extinción de 28 especies por
cada millón cada
y esto es por destrucción de la mente
los quiero invitar por un momento a que
se pongan en el hábitat del parque
nacional del nevado de toluca
es un hábitat a más de 3000 metros sobre
el nivel del mar
donde hay nieve cada año y cuando se
derrite enriquece el suelo que alimenta
las plantas de fósforo y de nitrógeno
esta estadística en nuestra comunidad lo
que implica es que año con año vamos a
ir perdiendo tres especies endémicas
y si en el volcán hay 30 especies
endémicas
al final del 2029 no contaremos con
ninguna
las especies de plantas son las bases de
todos los ecosistemas y de nuestro
futuro
recuerden que la diversidad es lo que
tenemos que dar para el mundo las
plantas endémicas de toluca son muy
importantes para entender la historia
evolutiva de las plantas con flores hoy
yo los quiero invitar a que se anudan
con estas plantas y con nuestro
ecosistema del volcán
y que lo visitan y que cuando lo visiten
saquen muchas fotos de las flores sin
tocarlas
que las compartan
que vayan a su mesa e identifiquen las
plantas que comen que les enseñen a los
niños de dónde vienen esas plantas
los invito a que visiten los herbarios y
los jardines botánicos donde muchos
científicos especialmente mujeres
botánicas están midiendo las
características y están más que felices
de enseñarles lo que significa un es ser
una especie y finalmente los invito a
ser exigentes y a demandar leyes que
protejan nuestros parques nacionales y
que las entendamos y las respetamos
porque recuerden la diversidad es
nuestra identidad
[Aplausos]